[Music]
this morning help is on the way to the
Florida Keys just in time Irma tossed
the boats on to the streets as it
slammed into the island chain yesterday
trailers overturned and debris now
covers the roads people who did not
evacuate who did not evacuate rather
were stranded when the storm hit Burma
is a strongest hurricane hit the Florida
Keys in 57 years Elaine Quijano of our
streaming network that CBS n is in Key
Largo to show us a destruction there
Elaine good morning good morning to you
Gail we're now getting a look at some of
what devastation was left behind here by
the storm surge in this particular area
a neighborhood that sits on the water
all the evidence of that storm surge is
around you see piles of debris things
like sliding glass doors mattresses
piles of wood cinder blocks that have
been broken same story across the way
and that property behind me here it was
definitely a difficult situation for
people who did decide to stay
frightening moments for those who
ignored the mandatory evacuation order
throughout the keys we know there is
debris that litters the streets a result
of that powerful surge that came along
with hurricane Irma I can tell you even
just making our way in here we saw
things like furniture we saw mattresses
we saw all kinds of things that should
not be in the middle of the street a
boat at one point was in a median all
evidence of just how forceful those
winds were we should mention that the
military is going to be bringing in some
relief VSM c-130 that are going to go to
marathon and drop off some supplies
things like water we know it was the
lower keys in the middle keys that were
hit especially hard and Nora that relief
effort continues as we speak Nora all
right Elaine thank you so much for your
reporting there